Barack Obama's vision was not to leave
10 million people uncovered he wanted
every single person in this country
covered my plan would do that your plan
would do not have to buy in they do not
have to buy it you just said that you
just said that two minutes ago you just
said two minutes ago that they would
have to buy it you said they would have
to buy to buy in if Paulo fire you are
you forgetting what you said it Maddox
intervene for
what you said just two minutes ago I
mean I can't believe that you said two
minutes ago that they had to buy in and
now you're saying they don't have to buy
you're forgetting that no money you're
automatically and radically enrolls
people regardless of whether they choose
to opt in or not if you lose your job
for instance his his health care plan
would not automatically enroll you you
would have to opt in my health care plan
would that's a big difference I'm
fulfilling in fulfilling the legacy of
Barack Obama and you're not that would
be surprised to him
Andrew yang